this morning apple themselves have  confirmed that three brand new macs are  coming at the upcoming event and to make  things even more confusing one of them  is gonna be a macbook if we are truly  getting a new macbook next month it will  definitely be a new entry-level macbook  pro we've established that we're getting  a high-end m1 pro and m1 max mac mini as  well as an entry-level macbook pro but  that still leaves one mystery eec filing  for a brand new mac let me go through  the possible scenarios for what it could  end up being there's a chance that two  of those eec filing numbers are for the  same new mac mini model the third eec  number has to be a different mac no  matter what what if the third mac is  gonna be a new apple silicon 27 inch mac  model that will come with just the m1  pro and max chips if apple is truly  revealing the m2 macbook pro next month  then why not release a second mac with  the m2 chip at the same time